we need to make our people less
vulnerable to the various diseases
whether it's chronic diseases like heart
disease and diabetes or the acute
diseases like covid-19 we need to make
them less vulnerable so we have to start
educating people up that health results
from healthful living
so we need to fight to improve the diet
and lifestyle habits of people because
honestly you're not going to completely
avoid exposure to every infectious agent
that comes along and we're not going to
be able to escape heart disease cancer
and diabetes unless we adopt healthful
habits so we should be incentivizing
encouraging intimidating whatever it
takes people to adopt a health promoting
diet lifestyle my opinion is that is
close to a whole plant food SOS free
diet with regular sleep and prioritized
uh regular exercise and prioritize sleep
as you can get that that's what's going
to result in Healthy Living diet sleep
exercise you do that you'll do more than
all the other job boning that's taking
place right now